how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the mc when today
we have so much to talk about because
the fantastic four are making their way
to the mcu and it sounds like according
to recent reports they're going to be
coming sooner than we thought they would
be coming
now we knew eventually they would show
up in the marvel cinematic universe
after disney acquired the rides to the
fox x-men characters including the
fantastic four
and including galactus so some very big
characters are on their way to the mcu
and it looks like we've discovered who
our next
thanos is our next big bad of the marvel
cinematic universe and we'll break down
everything that you need to know
including
when we can expect the fantastic four in
this video
if you're new and you love marvel be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest
mcu news and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win a
doctor strange funko pop
just subscribe like the video and leave
a comment down below to enter
galactus is the villain that we've been
waiting for the planet-eating cosmic
entity that very
very few have been able to take down in
the comics now one of those teams of
course and the team that is most
widely associated with galactus is the
fantastic four
and yesterday we heard the news that
marvel studios has filed the paperwork
for the fantastic four
it has been discovered that disney has
recently registered the names of two new
production companies one of those being
for the fantastic four
now the fantastic four were announced in
2019
san diego comic-con by kevin feige the
president of marvel studios himself so
we knew that they were going to be
coming eventually
and not to mention that marvel studios
has also filed paperwork for every
project they've announced at 2019 san
diego comic-con besides the fantastic
four
and blade but now reports say that they
have filed this for the fantastic four
meaning they're on their way
which means that galactus is on his way
and this is the villain that everybody
has been hoping for and looking forward
to
let's face it there's really only one
way to outdo the infinity saga to outdo
thanos and to outdo avengers endgame
you need a bigger villain and you need a
bigger story plot that's going to
eventually bring all of these new
different teams
the x-men the fantastic four the
avengers together at the end of this new
saga in a way that
end game couldn't do it so how do you
beat thanos and how do you beat avengers
end
game well you do it with galactus and
you do it with avengers
secret wars now there have been several
reports in the past from
several insiders stating that galactus
is coming and he is going to be the next
big bad of the mcu but now the fantastic
four
are on the production grid and that's
the first step in getting galactus into
the marvel cinematic universe and
there's a few other steps that have to
happen before galactus makes his huge
marvel cinematic universe debut the
first step like i said is the fantastic
four and
marvel already took that step in 2019
when they announced the fantastic four
coming to the mcu
they went even further this week by
registering the production company for
the fantastic four
so what happens next is the actual
appearance of the fantastic four
and the t's of galactus now if you think
back to the infinity saga and you think
about how marvel
teased thanos in the beginning before he
became the ultimate big bad
they did it rather well at the very end
of phase one in the post credit scene of
the avengers they teased
thanos they didn't tell you anything
about him but of course us fans knew who
he was and they set him up as a
looming presence he was a threat but it
wasn't that
immediate the other immediate threats
were people such as ultron
loki hydra etc but then we slowly
started to find out that thanos was
behind several different things and was
starting to collect the infinity stones
he made a pretty big appearance in the
guardians of the galaxy and then we saw
him once again in the post-credits scene
of avengers age of ultron and that is
when they officially revealed the
infinity
gauntlet and what his plans were the
same will happen for galactus and the
first teaser that we'll probably get for
him will be in a post-credit scene of
the fantastic four there are plenty of
villains for the fantastic four
the x-men and the avengers to fight
before galactus shows up so
just like the avengers fought loki and
ultron we're going to be getting
villains like kang and annihilus before
galactus shows up and they also have to
set the new teams up before he shows up
as well
because remember galactus is the big bad
not the one-off villain that the
avengers or the x-men take care of in
one movie
he's going to be the villain that it
might even take three movies for the
avengers the x-men and the fantastic
four to defeat
but he will be the villain who brings
all of these teams together
so the fantastic four enter the mcu
teasing galactus and then the x-men
enter as well
now of course the x-men will have their
own threats but will definitely get
another teaser for galactus at some
point and they'll also establish some
key characters that play
a role in defeating galactus such as the
child of
reed richards and sue storm franklin
richards
the son of mr fantastic and the
invisible woman an omega
level mutant one of the strongest
mutants and one of the strongest
characters in marvel history and all of
the teams are definitely going to need
him
at one point in time in the comics he
raises galactus from the dead and uses
him
basically as a puppet to defeat some
cosmic entities now of course he
probably won't be this strong in the mcu
but the teams will need him nonetheless
now one of the first teasers for
galactus is most likely going to be
the silver surfer another character
associated widely with a fantastic four
and super anticipated to make his mcu
debut
the silver surfer is undoubtedly the
most popular herald of galactus for
those of you who are unaware galactus is
a cosmic entity who needs to consume
planets to sustain his life force so he
literally consumes
planets and he creates heralds who he
grants part of his power to
and they seek out planets for galactus
to consume the silver surfer as a herald
of galactus would end up going to earth
however the silver surfer would end up
betraying galactus and with the help of
the fantastic four they drove galactus
away
however galactus would return to earth
many different times
and this is most likely something that
we will see happen in the mcu
we will see a herald of galactus appear
and that will be the first threat that
the
teams are going to have to take care of
and once they take care of the herald
they will learn about the future threat
of galactus coming to earth
and this is going to be what brings all
of our teams together the avengers the
x-men the fantastic four
but not only the teams from our main
universe we know that the multiverse is
going to play a
really big part in the future phases of
the mcu
and we know that they're going to be in
a little bit of chaos and we know that
because of doctor strange and the
multiverse of
madness so galactus coming and the fact
that the multiverse is going to exist
and being madness
leads us to believe that the future and
final event of this next saga
is going to be secret wars battle world
an event where you see
multiple different versions of
characters from different realities all
come together and fight together and
this would be
another way to top the events of
avengers infinity war and avengers in
game
not only will you have multiple teams
coming together to fight galactus but
you'll have multiple versions of
different characters from different
realities
we'll have multiple thors multiple star
lords multiple versions of the fantastic
four the x-men
wolverine all coming together to stop
galactus
now there's much more to secret wars in
the comics but we don't know how it's
going to play out in the mcu
but we do know that galactus is coming
and he's coming sooner than we thought
right now if we follow the pattern that
marvel studios has done
in the past we can expect the fantastic
four to begin production at marvel
studios somewhere between august 2021
and february 2022 and marvel studios
usually starts projects 12 to 15 months
before they're expected to hit theaters
and it just so happens that marvel
studios has two film dates reserved for
untitled movies right now
one october 7th of 2022 and one
february 17th of 2023 so if we base the
new fantastic four production on what
marvel studios has done in the past
the october and february date could be
when we see the fantastic four make
their official
mcu debut setting the groundwork for the
next mcu's
big bad galactus so what do you think
about the fantastic four making their
way to the mcu pretty soon and what do
you think about galactus being the next
big bad let me know what you think in
the comments down below and let me know
what you
hope to see from him and i know a lot of
us don't want to see a giant cloud again
be sure to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all the
latest
mcu news for live updates you can follow
me on twitter and as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof
you